So we're about to run the newSaga function for a second time.
And the important issue here is that we will create a brand new red context,
which will be the home for a new foil variable and two new blue contexts.
The other interesting thing here is that the sagas array is going to now have
two different function objects in it as a result of the second call to .push.
Let's examine the situation further by imagining that there were even more
calls to the two different saga functions here before the end of the program.
Running the first saga function again should work just like it did
the other times we ran it even though we've created a second newSaga context.
And as we can see as we run the code, running that inner sagas function creates
a new blue sagas context inside the first red newSaga context.
That's because we're running the first of those saga functions.
The first of the saga functions was created in the first of
the newSaga contexts.
What do you expect the output to be this time?